merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et concerne le projet de la loi sur le
travail dont la teneur est de plus en
plus incertaine monsieur le premier
ministre
permettez-moi de vous rappeler à la mode
dans l'inventaire à la prévert les
marques de votre préparation et de votre
improvisation sur ce sujet votre
gouvernement se voulait exemplaire
or ils brûlent les étapes et n'a pas su
donner à la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux la place qu'elle
aurait dû avoir
on peut citer également l'article de
l'avant projet de loi concernant
licenciements économiques ajouté
semble-t-il au tout dernier moment
toujours sans dialogue social est alors
que ce texte n'est toujours pas déposé
vous êtes aujourd'hui contraint de
reprendre la main et d'engager un cycle
de concertation à la dernière minute
pour le réécrire entre le conseil d'état
et à conseil des ministres reporté de
deux semaines tout ça pour arriver au
résultat probable d'un texte vidé d'une
part d'une grande partie de sa substance
le constat est accablant pas de
consensus syndical pas d'assise
parlementaire forte la contestation à
tavaux propres rangs et face à une
simple pétition vous battez déjà en
retraite devant tant de légèreté dans la
conduite de l'action gouvernementale qui
réduit vos marges de manoeuvre et
mettent en danger des dispositions qui
allaient dans le bon sens
ma question sera simple êtes vous
conscient de la lourde responsabilité
qui pèse sur vous par votre
improvisation vous avez provoqué un
mouvement social sans doute de grande
ampleur en période d'état d'urgence et
de menace accrue
nos étudiants et nos lycéens
manifesteront demain à paris et dans
toutes nos villes de province à l'appel
de responsable mais le sont-ils vraiment
politiques et syndicaux aussi pouvez
vous assurer la représentation nationale
et nos concitoyens que toutes les
mesures de sécurité seront prises pour
la protection de notre jeunesse
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri mise du travail dans l'emploi la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marie louise fort vous nous interroger
sur la méthode relative à cette loi je
pense que le
avoir ouvert un cycle de concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux étaient
utiles et est utile parce que cette loi
juste titre aux des débats à l'issue
d'une semaine après ma nomination une
semaine après ma nomination
le rapport de jean denis combrexelle
nous été remis à cette occasion nous
avons fait la proposition à l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux
si au titre de l'article l 1 du code du
travail il souhaitait ouvrir une
négociation sur les suites à donner au
rapport de jean denis combrexelle
ils ne l'ont pas souhaité et dans ce
cadre là j'ai mené tout un cycle de
bilatérales sur toute la partie relative
au temps de travail son compte personnel
d'activité l'accord des partenaires
sociaux sur le compte personnel
d'activité est en effet arrivé
tardivement
et puis en effet il ya eu des arbitrages
qui ont été rendus tardivement et qui
ont fait que le texte qui s'est retrouvé
dans la presse n'était pas la réalité du
texte en effet cette séquence n'a été
j'en conçois tout à fait un peu
difficile et je pense que c'est le sens
d'une gouvernance ouverte aussi de
savoir prendre quinze minutes quinze
jours pardon pour revoir avec l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux
l'ensemble de ces démarches ça veut dire
qu'il y à des actes des améliorations à
apporter à ceux tels vous plaît c'est
pour cela que nous les travaillons
aujourd'hui dieu merci et bravo sommes
créés
l'objectif de ce projet loi s'est arrêté
de répondre à la france telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
il y a bien sûr des points d'équilibré à
trouver c'est nécessaire mais moi je ne
considère pas que le dialogue social est
une perte de temps là dans votre
intervention vous faites une ode aux
partenaires sociaux et dans
l'intervention jus tout à l'heure on
nous disait qu'il ne représentait que
même nous nous croisons nous croyons en
la négociation collective et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que nous augmentons
les moyens donc ce temps est nécessaire
merci la parole est à madame aude ollier